it was on this date in 2003 new york
giants were up
38 to 14 with four minutes in change to
go in the third quarter
and with jeff garcia and tara owens
firing in all cylinders and the 49ers
got back in this game came back in this
game
became only the second team in the
history of the nfl to come back from 24
more points down in the playoff game
frank reich's buffalo bills against the
houston
as the other one but it almost didn't
happen
as a successful comeback because the
giants had a 42-yard
field goal all set up to win the game
for jim fossil and the giants
trey junkin one of the best long
snappers in his day
a botched snap matt allen the holder
couldn't hold it
put it down for matt bryant and all of a
sudden a fire drill breaks out
matt allen throws it downfield a rich
cyborg a left a guard
who who actually reported is eligible
before all of us
pulled down by cheeky okafor no flag
the only flag on the plate was for an
illegal man downfield on the offensive
line for the giants
because who knew there was a past
attempt coming
should have been offsetting penalties as
head of nfl ref's mike pereira at the
time
said giants fans still pissed
you know who's not pissed the man who
has seen a hug and uh
jim fossil on the screen my buddy from
nfl gameday morning
steve mariachi happy anniversary mooch
that's a good recap thank you for just
bringing that up to me that's a fond
memory that i have you know
you know what down 38 to 14
in the third quarter i remember it well
rich
i grabbed my two coordinators a napper
dignap
and jim morrow is junior right i said
guys whatever the heck whatever the heck
our game plan was
forget about it change everything man
we're we're desperate right now because
i was looking at that scoreboard i
thought maybe it's going to end up a
50 burger against us oh geez but boy did
the uh
momentum you know all momentum changes
right moments
right said this the other day on game
day morning
and there were some moments man and
garcia scored a touchdown t.o scored a
touchdown got some two-point plays and
the whole thing and thai streets from
michigan squared on double post to go
ahead
38-37 crowd was crazy
it was the most unbelievable game that
rich that was my last game in that
stadium
is that right your last gaming
candlestick huh i didn't know that
yeah that was my last that was my last
coaching
day uh date um for the 49ers that was it
your last playoff win then because uh
wow unbelievable and then of course
tomorrow's the anniversary
of the press conference where you were
told what mike pereira had to say
that the giants should have gotten the
ball back with another attempt to try
and
get that game-winning field goal and
your response was what again steve
bummer i mean
bummer great response mooch you know
what
i'm not always at a loss for words but i
mean
you know they asked me they go hey mike
pereira said
that i mean this is 24 hours after the
whole city is celebrating i mean it was
like a
it was like a great day right in
candlestick and
and uh and so we were on a high note
we're getting ready for our next game
against the champs tampa
and uh so all of a sudden he informs me
that mike pereira said oh they made a
mistake
there was a there should have been a
penalty on both teams
you know replay the down and there's
like what do you want me to do apologize
or like
look back and play it over again i just
said bummer i mean
and boy did i hear about that rich
well i i know you still new york people
are you know they're just going to just
get all over you right
and now all of a sudden i'm getting i'm
getting messages and i'm getting hate
mail and
and then the funny thing about it is not
too funny
we go to tampa to play the divisional
round
and uh they're the you know they won
they won the super bowl that year they
were a terrific team with sapp and john
lynch and all those guys
derek brooks anyway they beat us so
so i get fired i get fired
out of the playoffs why am i laughing
and uh yeah the new york people were
sending me
cards and messages hey mariucci you got
fired bummer i mean i mean they wouldn't
let me forget about it man it was
awesome steve mariucci here
on the rich eisen show and now we've got
another uh the current giants coach is
really
upset uh joe judge i don't know if you
heard his soliloquy
yesterday um so let's take this one
piece at a time
here uh i know we were all on a text
exchange
uh as we always are on the game day
morning crew watching
you know nationally televised games of
importance and we're going back and
forth with each other
uh i know you were mystified with what
was going on on sunday night football
what uh what what what do you think
happened it sure looks like the
the uh the eagles decided to pull the
plug to save their better draft position
to me steve yeah that's what it looked
like i uh
and let me practice this whole thing by
saying i have all the respect in the
world for doug peterson
sorry not just because he was one of my
backup quarterbacks to read farv in
green bay and i've known him and i
respect the job that he's done he's one
of the very few guys that are currently
coaching with a super bowl ring
okay i mean so his resume speaks for
itself
um and and i'm not making excuses for
him but here's a team that's out of the
playoffs
okay they're out they're out they're not
playing for the giants they're not
playing for the redskins they're not
playing for anybody except themselves
and and he's and he a lot of guys didn't
play
like 10 starters were out and then i was
a little curious why he didn't even suit
up carson wentz you know because to me
in case
jalen were to get hurt you can put
carson wins back in and
he's practiced up ready to go and
healthy and maybe you can finish the
game and win the game with
him but he used in pajamas on the
sidelines so
this was in to me it was like all right
this is jalen's team
probably next year too going to the
future it looks like it's
jalen hurts his team right so evidently
he must have told
nate sutfeld you know the quarterback
that's been around there for four years
that hey i'll get you in the game you
know it doesn't mean anything to us
and we're you know i'd like to you know
throw you a bone maybe and let you play
some or
whatever that is and that's that's cool
you know taking care of your players and
giving a guy a chance to you know get on
the field and
blah blah blah well the game was such
that any to me any promises that you
made or any intentions that you may have
had
you know those are maybe out the window
now because it's a competitive game
it's a three-point game and and uh
and all of a sudden to me it was like
just try to win this game it would be
very beneficial for jalen hurts
to finish a game try to you know with
the two-minute drill
and try to come from behind in a close
game and arrival
it's great for his development for the
future and then all of a sudden the
other kids in and
gail and i were watching the game she
looked at me she goes who's that
and i said let's watch i i don't know
what's going on
maybe it's hurt and i thought so but i
don't see anybody going in any tents
okay and i don't see any doctors hanging
out with
jaylen no smelling salt nothing they're
just putting the camera on his face and
i'm going
oh my god they're just they switch
quarterbacks with
in a three-point game and then so i'm
going all right well maybe this kid is
good maybe he'll win the game maybe
he'll play well he didn't play well
and i was i was kind of dumbfounded a
little bit why
why they didn't keep jalen hurst just
for jalen hurt's sake
no exactly and that's the whole point is
that you know
it looked like and you could see the
facial reactions though
of the players on the sidelines they did
not want this they wanted to finish up
they wanted to they wanted to finish up
jalen hurts
wants to finish up and you would think
that for the development of jalen hurts
to be able to say in the offseason we
beat the team
that otherwise would have won the
division you know and sure that the
giants got in but
at least you know there is some wind it
is at his back right there and
and don't you think peterson has got
some considerable if he is still the
coach there and i'm assuming he will be
he's got some considerable damage
control that joe judge
i think and i said in my first segment
here steve joe judge's comments weren't
just directed at his own locker room in
the league and at doug peterson
he i think he's trying to stir that up
in the philadelphia eagles locker room
by saying stuff like that
steve yeah well you know and and joe's
joe's i don't know joe um and i i
from what i watch he's a good guy good
coach and all that but you know he
should he should kind of coach his own
team but
um you know it's a decision that's what
coaches get paid for decisions and
in in personnel decisions and when you
pull your quarterback
all that and who plays and who rests and
other teams arresting players and
you know that sort of thing so evidently
doug didn't give a darn about new york
giants and their team
and uh so he just kind of had a plan and
and i think he stuck to it
he probably reluctantly stuck to that
plan to let the other kid play
he probably was hoping it was a they
were up by two touchdowns and he could
just play and explain it easy hey we
just let the kid play but it was a three
in the or be down by
20 points and just say hey well you know
it's over let's get play
but in a game that's even that was the
that was the thing that was
you know concerning not concerning but
just um baffling to me was
it's it's still a competitive game this
is not a time to be looking at
or you know throwing guys a bone or
anything but hey that's a decision he
make
you know not my circus but i uh
wait stirred it up talk about renewed
arrive a rivalry now this is these two
guys and these two teams are going to be
just
at each other's throats did you ever get
asked did you ever get asked to
what what we're assuming peterson was
asked to do uh
which is take a knee on a game for a
draft position did
have you ever been in that position ever
in our career
no no that's gotta i mean i i
yeah i don't know i don't know how that
works i i um
and i i it's hard to
you saw the jets rich they weren't they
didn't give a darn about draft no i'm
aware of this players and those coaches
on that team
didn't give a damn about trevor lawrence
that's obvious
because they weren't going to be there
half the team's not going to be there
next year they're they're thinking about
themselves and this year in the in the
here and now
right they don't care about the future
and you know maybe maybe uh
ownership or front office might think
about future once in a while but not
to extend to throw a game i i can't
imagine can't imagine
steve mariucci here on the rich eisen
show now let me put you in a position
you've also never been in which is uh
being covered positive
with a playoff game that you got to
coach uh coming up on the weekend
uh that's now stefan kevin stefanski's
world
for cleveland testing positive for
covert this very morning
uh mike garafolo our colleague at nfl
media
and nfl network saying that it looks
like it's gonna be alex van pelt
from the staff calling the plays and
mike prefer the uh special teams
coordinator being the
de facto head coach what is stefanski's
challenge
this week other than obviously having to
stay healthy we hope he is asymptomatic
but what do you what is what does he
have to do
knowing that he will not be part of this
thing right now at first i heard that
rich
um that's tough
and thankfully they got a play caller
there that's uh
like-minded and and can call the game
but uh they're
they're not even gonna let them be
around the facility or or that's right
or anything right that is correct and uh
you'll probably be involved with zoom
calls and
that type of thing during the prep week
so how do you do that how
how do you uh you know having a guy in
van pelt who knows you're thinking and
obviously
is an offensive minded guy but how how
would you
first blush go about making sure
you know hey if this happens let's call
this play if that happens call that play
try to
download him with as much without trying
to clog his head
uh with with all that much does that
make sense
is that i mean yeah you know what you
know what rich um and
i've i haven't been through the covet
thing but i've been through
before passing the baton to a play
caller
you know i call the plays in san
francisco
um until i gave that to marty morningwig
all right
i called and then eventually napper and
i called the plays
in detroit until i gave that up as well
but you only give it up to people that
you you know
by i mentioned the word like-minded
right um
that know your offense that knows
how your game plan and how you you know
tend to call plays and what you like
what you don't like and so
so you know van pelt's going to be uh
he's going to be a good play caller he's
going to be a lot like
kevin's friends he's not going to like
in install the wishbone this right and
he's going to run
he's going to do what they do and do
what they do best and and so
um luckily he's got that to fall back on
that's uh that's really important um
you know to have somebody qualified to
do something like that not every
not every staff has that next guy
up uh if your play caller on either side
of the ball
is is is out for some reason it'd be
like your quarterback being hurt you got
to have a backup right
and i and i think the browns probably
have a pretty darn good backup but
that's really unfortunate steve mariucci
here on the rich eisen show before i let
you go mooch
um now that we are turning the page to
the super
wild card weekend which um
six seven seed let's throw the browns in
there too if you want
uh you got the colts and obviously
you've got the bears going to the saints
you've also got uh the rams assuming
you know it's either going to be walford
again or or goff coming off the
off the hand which one do you think has
got an opportunity here or do you think
um we're we're not going to see much of
an upset over this weekend
what do you got for me well i think the
ram seahawks can be a game that goes
right down to the wire
that rams defense can you know plays
well against the seahawks
um that's that's going to be an
interesting how about john wilford huh
he left the team in
porsche course passing but rushing too
and that defense is pretty salty
um that'll be interesting and then uh
i don't i don't know if the i don't know
if the bears can can beat the saints but
hey on any given sunday i that's that's
a tough
that's a tough out for the browns to go
into pittsburgh and win this game
with a with a well-rested uh steeler
team
that was smart on tomlin's part to rest
ben and tj watt and
and and those guys very smart because
they really haven't had their buy
in months and they needed this so
that'll be a fun game i
i like the colts and not what they're
doing but i just don't see them going
into orchard park
uh and and winning that game against the
bills the bills are
really a scary team right now they are
aren't they really good i mean
alan is he is i can you say blossomed i
mean
that it's more than that he's exploded
you know you know so
so remember in the draft and you do a
great job over at combine in the draft
and all that stuff rich
remember when he was coming out he was
statistically now
you know what i really looked into this
he's a california kid he's right from
the valley right down here okay a little
fireball a little town
and then he ends up with really only two
offers and he goes to wyoming
and he wasn't a very accurate passer
right
big gangly kid that needed to learn how
to play quarterback
and that kind of haunted him
early in his career at the bills he his
completion percentage wasn't very good
and i looked at it in college because
these other guys are thrown for 73
completions well a lot of that
completion percentage stuff is all these
these uh horizontal throws out to the
flat and these screens and these quick
throws and smokes and all this baloney
and jet sweeps from shotgun which really
inflates that completion percentage and
he didn't
he didn't do much of that in college so
i'm going yeah you know the types of
throws
uh make that completion percentage a
little bit less right
but for two years he was still down
there at the bills
well he has blossomed like crazy right
now he's he makes all the throws he's
accurate he's and you know what steve
young told me when when uh
when when he was playing he says he said
mooch when i was at byu they were going
to make me a db
because i wasn't a good enough
quarterback they were going to move me
to corner
and i begged him to let me play one more
spring
at quarterback so they let him do that
and he stayed at quarterback and he said
even at tampa bay when he went there
usfl in tampa bay he said i wasn't a
very accurate quarterback
i became a better uh more accurate
quarterback
not just because of my mechanics but my
understanding of
timing and anticipation and location and
you know
those types of things so josh allen is
learning those types of things right now
and uh that's that's scary for that
division because he's not going anywhere
he's going to be around there for
another decade
and getting better and better and it
could be scary for the conference too
we'll see how
how far the bills can go if if they do
get past the colts
uh and i got jonathan taylor on
tomorrow's show we'll talk about that
matchup a little bit more and then
oh good and then obviously you and i are
will be spending an absurd amount of
time together with uh
two shows uh over the weekend i'm
looking forward to it i can't wait it's
gonna be awesome
i mean wild card weekend six big games
are you kidding me this is fantastic
i agree with you happy anniversary again
steve thank you
let's do this each year this is just a
great memory
it's my last great memory in candlestick
you know
i know just keep it live will you okay
you got it you take care
mooch i'll see you saturday i'll see you
soon okay yeah one of my favorite people
steve mariucci